The aftershock shuddered through the
Foundation, emergency alarms wailed
as injured staff and security helped each
other out from underneath rubble that had
fallen on them as the building was shaken by the
quake. It had only lasted a few short seconds,
but still managed to leave a trail of destruction
in its wake. While the wounded were bandaged up,
anyone and everyone who was still able to
started frantically checking the containment
of every anomaly on the site. The Foundation could
worry about the origin of the quake later. First
and foremost, they needed to assess the damage.
Luckily, multiple rapid sweeps of the facility
revealed that there weren’t all that many
high-threat level anomalies whose containment
had been breached. A few of the safer ones
were found cowering under tables, or buried
under fallen rubble in their quarters. But, for
the most part, every anomaly was accounted for,
and none had been provided with an opportunity
to escape and cause further havoc. At least,
that’s how things seemed at first.
It was only when the chaos started to die down,
and repair efforts went underway that personnel
noticed an odd change. Something was missing,
but nobody could quite put their finger
on exactly what. As a matter of fact,
most could pinpoint exactly when they noticed this
odd feeling: it had only begun after the emergency
alarms had been shut off. There was a sound that
everyone working at the Foundation had gotten so
used to that they’d practically stopped hearing
it, or at least, they’d stopped noticing it.
It was only now that the noise was gone, its
absence no longer drowned out by blaring alarms,
that staff realized. It had always been there;
everyone had just learned to subconsciously
tune it out:
Crying.
The low, soft whimpering that could often be heard
emanating from SCP-096’s containment chamber. It
had stopped. The cell within had fallen silent.
And, once someone at the Foundation made the right
connection and investigated, they happened upon a
startling discovery. SCP-096 had vanished. Panic
immediately engulfed the facility yet again.
The Shy Guy could be anywhere, and a search
effort to find it would only end in deaths.
After all, in order to find something,
you have to look at it, and that was a
fatal thing to do when SCP-096 was involved.
Closer examination showed no trace of the missing
creature. There had been no reported incidents
of incursions with it from anywhere in the
world. Every known photograph, video recording,
or other visual depiction of SCP-096 was either
securely stashed away or destroyed completely by
the Foundation. There was no way it could have
possibly escaped, and it was seemingly nowhere
at all. But still, the question remained:
where in the world had the Shy Guy gone to?
If it was still even in this world.
From SCP-096’s perspective, one moment,
all had been normal. The next, it was lost
somewhere strange, unfamiliar, and above all,
unsettling, even to the Shy Guy. Before the sudden
quake had hit, it had spent the day the same way
it usually occupied its time; alternating between
aimlessly pacing the far wall of its containment
chamber, and sitting in a fetal position in
the corner, sobbing all the while. But then,
the room had started shaking, and in the
blink of a deeply sunken eye, the Shy Guy
found itself… well, it had no idea where.
Around it was a large, carpeted room, open
and sparse, with little occupying all the space.
The wallpaper was a nauseating, sickly shade of
yellow, made all the more garish by the rows of
fluorescent lighting from the ceiling above. The
entire place seemed to resemble an office space,
although seemingly one that was in a total state
of disuse. There was no furniture, not even one
solitary, inanimate object to make the place
seem at least the tiniest bit closer to normal.
Little was SCP-096 aware, it had somehow been
transported to a strange and terrible place:
the Backrooms. Unless someone remains wary and
ever-vigilant, they can unknowingly slip their
way out of reality. It can happen anywhere,
all that a person needs to do is be in the
wrong place at the wrong time, and they will
noclip into the Backrooms. All around SCP-096 was
the stench of old, wet carpet, and a labyrinth
of uninhabited rooms with the same drab yellow
walls, the endless buzz of the fluorescent lights,
stretching out for who knows how many square
miles of empty rooms. In short, the Shy Guy
was trapped in a purgatory-like nightmare.
However, there was at least one small mercy
for SCP-096 as it wandered around its new
surroundings. There was nobody else around,
no other signs of life. No SCP Foundation,
no ordinary human beings, no one who could
see it. Here, in the solitary confinement of
the Backrooms, SCP-096 could not be perceived.
And yet, this brought the self-conscious
creature very little in the way of comfort.
Despite being completely alone, there was an
awful, lingering feeling that hung in the air like
the smell of the old carpet underfoot. SCP-096
still felt like it was being watched. And yet,
if someone – or something – really was
watching, it wasn’t triggering the Shy
Guy’s usual rage state. As it lurked
through the various rooms and corridors,
the creature kept expecting to find someone, to
look them in the eye directly and get that same,
inescapable urge to race towards its observer
and kill them. But it never came, because there
was nobody else around. At least, for a while.
Adam Jenkins had been just out riding his bike
when it happened. Pushing one pedal around,
then the other, he gradually climbed higher
up the slope of a hill. His house was
down at the bottom on the other side,
and Adam knew, once he reached the peak, he could
slip nice and easily down the rest of the way. As
long as he was careful not to let the extra
momentum carry his bike too far and too fast,
he just had to keep in control and gently
compress the brake if he needed to. He made this
same journey every day, nothing could go wrong…
Sure enough, Adam reached the top of the hill,
and allowed the bike to slowly tip ever
so slightly over the other side. Gravity
started to do the rest, the wheels starting to
spin rapidly, the pedals pistoning his legs as
he plummeted downwards. It was one of the few
childlike joys left in Adam’s life, those few
brief seconds of the day where he got to speed
down the hill back home with reckless abandon.
He was blissfully unaware that he wouldn’t have
enough time to miss how much he enjoyed it.
Without warning, a car came speeding out from
around a corner on the way down the hill. It
was dark, and the driver had carelessly decided to
leave their headlights off. So, when Adam saw the
vehicle, he only had a split second to react. He
was still going too fast, so he applied the brakes
now, his front wheel would stop too suddenly
and send him flying forward over the handlebars.
Instead, seconds before colliding with the car’s
hood, Adam wrenched his bike’s handlebars and
swerved around the car. But the added speed of
going downhill caused the entire bike to topple
as it turned so violently, launching Adam off
and sending him hurtling towards a nearby wall.
Adam could tell, in the split second after
coming off his bike, that he was about to
collide with the wall. His brain and body
anticipated the impact, bracing him for
the painful crash. But it never came. Instead
of hitting the wall, Adam passed through it.
That may well have spared him a devastating
injury, but now a whole new problem now faced
him. Just like no clipping through a virtual
environment in a video game, Adam had passed
directly out of reality… right into the Backrooms.
The first few hours were the worst, shouting as
loud as he could for someone, anyone to come and
find him. Each yell rapidly growing more and more
frantic as Adam rushed around his haunting new
surroundings. The whole place was unsettling just
to be in, it gave off a hostile, unwelcoming
energy that was impossible to ignore. It was
only after an hour of trying to find a way out
that Adam realized: he was well and truly lost.
He’d strayed too far away from his original point
of entry, and just as he had the idea of trying
to make his way back to the world from the same
place he came in, it was already too late. The
Backrooms - at least on this first level - all
looked the same, no two rooms were distinct enough
for him to figure out if this was somewhere
he’d been before, or an entirely new area.
It didn’t take long for an overwhelming sense of
hopelessness to set in. Adam had quickly given
up calling for help: there was no sign of anyone
around that would be able to help him. Until the
shuffling of footsteps came from nearby. It was
such a noticeable break in the dull, unsettling
quiet of the Backrooms that it made Adam’s ear’s
prick up. The yellow-hued maze had been so void of
life since he arrived, so unnaturally empty, that
he wasn’t entirely sure he hadn’t made the sound
himself, by his jacket brushing up against a wall.
But no, there was definitely something here
with him, he could hear it wandering about
nearby. And it had certainly heard him too.
Calling out again, with more caution in his
tone, Adam Jenkins turned the next corner, met
with yet another dingy yellow corridor. Although,
unlike the others, this one had a key difference:
SCP-096 stood right in the middle of it. The split
second that Adam’s eyes fell over the Shy Guy,
it was already too late. He barely had time to
process the sight of the creature; it’s tall,
humanoid shape, wiry thin and pale-skinned,
jaw hanging unnaturally wide. In fact,
SCP-096 dashed towards Adam so quickly, that
he couldn’t even finish his startled scream…
Meanwhile, back at the SCP Foundation, efforts
were still underway to retrieve the Shy Guy.
Researchers were baffled that there was
not a single trace anywhere on the globe
of SCP-096’s presence. They had quickly rolled out
their usual method for recalling the creature to
containment. Requisitioning one of D Class
personnel, this individual was instructed
to stand in SCP-096’s cell and then given a
photograph of the monster to look at. Knowing
that the Shy Guy would track down anyone that
saw its face – even as a single, tiny pixel in
a picture – the Foundation expected the creature
to simply reappear in its containment chamber to
kill the D Class that they had used as bait.
But nothing happened. The D Class was able
to look at the photo of SCP-096 and survive. It
was almost as if the creature’s link to reality
was weakened; wherever it was, it might
still be aware someone had looked at it,
but the Shy Guy was somehow being blocked
from traveling to its most recent observer.
Having drawn a blank on trying to determine
SCP-096’s whereabouts, the Foundation eventually
turned to SCP-343 for his input. Naturally, the
powerful reality bender was reluctant as ever
to get involved. The Foundation insisted, knowing
that SCP-343’s omniscience meant he would already
be aware of where they could find the missing
Shy Guy. He refused multiple times, admitting
he did indeed have the answer they were looking
for, but not wishing to divulge that information.
“Fine,” SCP-343 sighed, coming to a
compromise. “I can’t tell you exactly
where 096 is. But when I tell you where
to look for answers, you’ll know: ASYNC.”
The researchers were stunned into silence.
Nobody in the Foundation had heard that name
used in a long time. But SCP-343 was right – they
knew exactly what it meant. Back in the 1980s,
ASYNC was another shadowy organization that
had been investigating the existence of a
liminal space connected to reality. A
place they had called the Backrooms.
Gathering up a Mobile Task Force, the SCP
Foundation dispatched its agents to a site
that had long since been abandoned. They’d
kept a watchful eye over the disused lab,
keeping the public away, making sure nobody
stumbled in by accident and got trapped. As
the MTF commander gave the word, the outdated
80s technology was fired up, and ASYNC’s great
achievement was reactivated. They had constructed
a portal into the Backrooms. Moving in formation,
the MTF operatives filed into the empty yellow
space, unsure if they’d find SCP-096 alive… or
if it would even want to come back.
Meanwhile, in the Backrooms Level 0,
only the Shy Guy remained - having completely
annihilated poor, unfortunate Adam. He was
enjoying the solitude once again, knowing that
now, nobody was here to see him. Until one wrong
step changed everything: He noclipped from Level
0 to Level 1, where he’d have a lot more company…
Now go and check out “SCP-096 VS SCP-343”
and “SCP-096 VS SCP-106” for more!